[Musique]
les peu d'écrits salut visiteurs venus
d'une autre planète
il n'y a plus de raison de se battre
vous voyez amis ils sont nés lucie et
d'autres approches toi tu es feuilles
planty
[Musique]
en mai je t'en prie je m'appelle rex rex
danger ça c'est mon vaisseau s'était dit
nos jeunes et qu'est ce que tu fais dans
l'espace
ils sont kidnappés mes amis je fais les
récupérer cette planète est dirigée par
une race extraterrestre angers si la
reine aux mille visages un cheval qui
parle et je peux prendre une autre
parente si ça vous met plus à l'aise que
veut on rechange et le cheval était
beaucoup plus satisfaisant
accompagnement dans cette aventure pour
sauver mes amis apprends moi à être plus
dur bien allons sauver des amis et qui
lui aussi dit nous le sunnite à l'air
différent j'étais dessiner des proches
départ pourquoi gilles non non pas du
tout pardon madame n'a même pas glisser
son sa peau de banane
tu vas finir en suisse
vous avez failli oublier les amis je
crois enfin chez une lanterne comme on
peut ne pas me voir